foreign he takes the opening face off against
Robert Thomas established nhler and this will
be a fun matchup tonight to see Bedard versus
Thomas on the top lines for their respective teams
oh nice move here's Bedard Over The Line
Bedard drags shoots rebound Hall out to Seth Jones
is saved by Hofer he was ready on the edge of the
crease exactly right so great skating ability
cuts through the middle gets around butchnavich
and Thomas and then he cuts now and he makes it
so that there's a lot more space a little toe drag
right there thanks for coming and you know the
blues bench are going to be saying boy don't don't
be watching the puck watch his chest now Robert
Thomas tests Peter mrazik first shot on goal for
the blues because he creates a lot of commotion
there and makes it difficult for the goaltender
West McCall calling it Peter McDougall are
our referees tonight by the way as the puck
trickles under the glove of Joel Hofer did you
enjoy that conversation we had before the game
with Wes McCauley I was sad that he had to go get
ready to ref the game tonight yeah I mean just you
know he just he just brings some character to
the game but in this power play you'll see and
there's Wes McCauley number four big lacrosse fan
lead father in the Canadian lacrosse Hall of Fame
so here's Seth Jones drifting to the
top Donato oh Banger mentioned there's
a takeaway by Robert Thomas Thomas out to
meet him and the shot Buzz is behind the neck
a lot of guys from the development
program in Plymouth Michigan [Applause]
Drew camesso to play before he went to BU
100 regular season NHL games played
between Perry and Paulino power play
for the blues perunovic all the
way across and the shop wide and
behind the net from Paul Duke who blasts
another one right off Wyatt Kaiser Thomas
took his eye off the puck and Nick lardes
pounces on it lard is short-handed draws the
penalty and the save made by ho for a slashing
call and there's going to be the slashing call
there after bushnevich had that pass go off the
heel there goes largest terrific speed and if
you look at the some of the goals that lardus
has scored in some of the scoring chance zuzak
Works around kuroshev dusack backhanded off
morazic Puck loose and scooped up by glassic
here comes the big man Alex classic cut off
by Callie Rosen and he finds Reichel Reichel
to Kaiser Kaiser open Ice he shoots in a save
by Hofer Brian Boucher had the graveyard ship
3 A.M that was pretty fun torchinski looking
for Bedard loose on the crease and a score
traffic in front and the
Hawks break through [Music]
Phillip kuroshev with the first goal of the
preseason for the Hawks and kuroshev's got
some terrific hands and here's the
offensive abilities there kochinski
to Bedard redirection off the pad and
there's the forehand of the backhand
play with Hall in front of the net goalie's
got no chance in a great finish there right
here forehand backhand sharp angle and up over
the pads and into the net under the bar and in
here's Lucas Reichel with a burst Reichel to the
net and he tried to go up top and Hofer knocked
it down Lucas Reichel does and and it's shifting
now he protects the puck takes it on the forehand
folino got it taken by dozak who played the angle
Thomas for buchanovic in a massive save by camesso
four on five defending for the Hawks to
start the third period Nolan Allen you
saw him a moment ago he's in the Penalty Box
perunovic it's bull Duke back to perunovic
one-timer bull Duke and he's shut
down by camesso Molino and Perry
lead the counter for the Hawks Perry
drags in the puck just behind fellino
Thomas fires and scores
a ringer from Robert Thomas and the blues tied
the game in the third exactly nine minutes in
generating chances it's an NHL line with
neighbors Thomas and busnevich they enter
the Zone which nevich looks like he wants that
puck fast back from Thomas if you can see he
flares out he's looking for a one-timer
and Connor Murphy kind of a little bit
in no man's land right there coach nevich
up ice here's Skinner a rather Neighbors
[Applause]
Neighbors
across perunovic with Thomas in front [Applause]
look out Connor Bedard and he goes and it's
saved by cranley oh quick stick to steal that
puck right there and I think that puck was
rolling on him as he went to the backhand
Thomas pitches it in Neighbors [Applause]
coughed up but Thomas gets it back
Tucker with a blast Puck loose in the crease and
caneso Smothers it all tries to cut him off down
low for zuzak Pooch namix a shot saved by camesso
Thomas wide and maybe off the side of the net
zuzak couldn't handle it and it's stripped
by Bedard Bedard dropped off for Hall
got a shot away looked like Robert Thomas
was going to take the puck neighbors down low
pereco
High shot Kaiser knocks it down Thomas
picks it up blocked by Murphy and
end of regulation tied at one
get that you've got a good scoring
chance there's the win on the draw Bedard
see him alter the shot angle rebound
off the side of the net Ryan Donato
Donato Geeks backhand through the crease
kuroshette couldn't reach it oh good keeping
right there by kartinski kuroshev [Applause]
to korchinski Donato turns in fires it was
tipped by Rosen and into the screen that's
a heck of a shift right there great work all
the way around especially by Donato great there
was a one-man wrecking crew right here backhand
fake now he's trying to a little Jam play
played in front Kershaw can't get it there
but it's kept in that's that play by korginski
the instincts to be on his toes [Applause]
goalie playing his position very well here's
Hall in front Kaiser covered up by cranley
not playing his best against Bedard and
the Hawks in their prospects tournament
Kaiser was at that Prospect game in Minnesota
as well now Bedard open and a save by cranley
cranley wasn't going to be denied you remember
that prospects game that short side snipe that
the Conor Bedard had he went that time
trying to go high to the glove side and
was a good stop bull Duke knocked Away by
camesso puck loose in the Hawks and Dean to
his feet and here comes Bedard crowd on its
feet Bedard for Anthony to see you he scores
that's an overtime winner for the Hawks
it all starts in the defensive Zone and you can
see on the right side of your screen there's
happen to see you with that great stride of his
he goes forehand holds on for a second goes to the
backhand lifts it up but this is just a terrific
pass head man in the puck allowing athensu to
skate into it and after will cranley's made some
good saves he can't get this one here and there's
the pass right on the tape and a good hoister on
the backhand there by after nasiou to win the game